[Musik]
der Kampf ums Kapitol ist noch nicht
entschieden in einigen Staaten wird noch
ausgezählt doch so viel ist klar bei den
Zwischenwahlen in den USA bleibt der
erwartete Erdrutschsieg die rote Welle
für die Republikaner aus ein Dämpfer für
Donald Trump in seiner Partei läuft sich
ein möglicher Gegenkandidat für die
Präsidentschaftskandidatur war der
Gouverneur von Florida ronde Santes
sichert sich mit einem deutlichen Sieg
die zweite Amtszeit
damit herzlich willkommen zu einer
zdf-spezial an diesem so wichtigen Tag
für die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
die Demokratie stehe bei den
Zwischenwahlen auf dem Spiel hieß es im
Vorfeld da viele Kandidaten der
Republikaner die von Trump verbreitete
Lüge von den gefälschten Wahlen 2020
vertreten es steht das Regieren wird für
den amtierenden Joe Biden sicher nicht
einfacher da die Republikaner zwar kein
Erdrutschsieg aber wohl die Mehrheit im
Repräsentantenhaus gewonnen haben der
wichtige Senat dagegen ist noch umkämpft
in Wisconsin hat der Kandidat der
Republikaner nach einem Kopf an Kopf
Rennen den Sieg geholt in Nevada ist das
noch nicht entschieden in Georgia wird
es am 6 Dezember eine Stichwahl geben
und auch in Arizona ist noch nicht klar
wer gewonnen hat
von dort haben wir gleich einen
Stimmungsbild für sie doch zuerst
berichtet Johannes Hanau aus
Pennsylvania wo die Demokraten
überraschend einen Triumph gefeiert
haben
als John fatherman hemd's eigentlich wie
immer in Sweatshirt und Jeans am späten
Abend mit seiner Familie vor dem
Mikrofone trat war klar er hatte etwas
geschafft was für die US-Demokraten und
Präsident beiden noch von allergrößter
Bedeutung sein könnte
ich habe niemals damit gerechnet dass
wir die roten Gemeinden blau machen aber
wir haben dort getan was wir mussten und
das ist der Grund warum ich der nächste
US-Senator von Pennsylvania bin
klarer Sieg ist dann doch eine kleine
Überraschung denn Pennsylvania ist ein
klassisches wingstate Donald Trump hatte
hier mit 20.000 stimmenvorsprung
gewonnen Joe Biden vier Jahre später mit
80.000 jede Stimme zählt Wahlkampf bis
zur letzten Minute ein kleiner Diner in
der Gemeinde Lebanon wir warten sie auf
den republikanischen Kandidaten für den
senatmethos drinnen erzählt uns ein Fan
Fake Juden aus der Ukraine hätten vor
500 Jahren gemeinsam mit den Banken den
Plan geschmiedet die Menschen ganz
besonders die Amerikaner durch Kredite
zu versklaven aber damit sei bald
Schluss vor der Kamera wiederholte es
dann nicht Ankunft Mehmet Oz geschätzte
500 Millionen Dollar ist der schwer
Herzchirurg mit
eliteuniversitätsabschluss und voll und
ganz Ergebnis
Pennsylvania lieben wir Präsident Trump
aus ist auch Fernsehstar bis zur
Kandidatur mit eigener Show fast jeder
Amerikaner kennt ihn hilfreich in einer
Zeit in der es mehr um Show als um echte
Politik geht seine Fans vor dem Diner
begeistert
mit seiner Fernsehshow hat er vielen
Menschen geholfen die Leute folgen ihm
seit Jahres
drinnen Aufbruchstimmung bei den
überwiegend alten weißen Frauen und
Männern die Demokraten würden Amerika
zerstören mit höheren Steuern für die
Mittelschicht und steigendem
Haushaltsdefizit und überhaupt die
Drogenhändler die das vitanyl in die
Briefkästen werfen um die Kinder
abhängig zu machen
stimmt zwar alles nicht aber wen
interessieren in diesen Zeiten schon
auch Fakten nur das alles anders werden
muss ist klar
es gibt keine Regulierung der
Kreditkartenfirmen und der
benzinpreissteigerung du kannst dahin
gehen und 4,19 für die Gallone bezahlen
und hier nur vier Dollar 5 unsere
Wirtschaft muss in Ordnung gebracht
werden ohne Kapitalismus oder
Sozialismus
vibrierende Industriestadt hat ihre
besten Tage hinter sich hier wählen Sie
eher Demokraten hier musste John
feddermen klar gewinnen und den
Republikanern den Senatssitz abzujagen
fährt man ein Riese zwei Meter sieben
groß fast 160 Kilo schwer lag in den
Umfragen lange fahren dann ein
Schlaganfall von dem er sich zwei erholt
hat aber seitdem ging es in den Umfragen
bergab
auf der Straße treffen wir Ronda und
Veronica sie sind überzeugt dass die
Frauen diese wahlentscheiden werden das
Abtreibungsverbot dass die Republikaner
fordern hätte die Frauen mobilisiert
es war ein langer Weg und immer
versuchen Sie uns mit Gesetzen zu
unterwerfen wir sind es einfach leid
niemand hat das Recht mir zu sagen was
ich mit meinem Körper mache ganz
besonders nicht jemand vom anderen
Geschlecht
s noch auf den letzten Metern haben
ronder und Veronica gestern Morgen
versucht die Leute daran zu erinnern
bloß wählen zu gehen denn viel stehe bei
dieser Wahl auf dem Spiel
Java Pike County Arizona die beiden
Demokraten Jay Ruby und Mike Vogel haben
in den letzten Tagen noch einmal alles
gegeben um Wähler zu mobilisieren und
stimmen zu gewinnen sie zogen von Haus
zu Haus um im Gespräch für ihre Politik
und ihre Positionen zu werben und um in
diesem erzkonservativen Bezirk
Vorurteile und Feindbilder gegen
Demokraten abzubauen
die meisten Demokraten hier werden von
Sendern wie Fox News negativ
stigmatisiert wenn Leute uns treffen
dann bekommen Sie ein anderes Bild
Mike Vogel früher Lehrer jetzt Rentner
hat sich als Kandidat für den senatsitz
in Arizona beworben um zu verhindern
dass radikale Republikaner an die Macht
kommen
[Musik]
sollten wahlleutner Schlüsselpositionen
bekommen wie das Gouverneursamt oder das
des Innenministers von Arizona der für
die Wahlen zuständig ist dann ist es
sehr wahrscheinlich dass unsere Wahlen
künftig untergraben werden die
Republikaner haben diese Absicht sehr
deutlich geäußert
während Jay und Mike um jede Stimme für
die Demokraten kämpften bereiteten sie
sich nebenan schon auf das Schlimmste
vor
Bürgerkrieg so die düstere Prognose der
aus Keepers einer extremistischen
Gruppierung die der festen Überzeugung
ist dass Donald Trump die Wahl gestohlen
wurde und die Demokraten ihr Land und
ihre Verfassung bedrohen
ich glaube nicht nur dass es in Amerika
einen Bürgerkrieg geben wird ich bin der
Überzeugung dass wir mittendrin sind
Bürgerkriege entstehen nicht über Nacht
sie entwickeln sich allmählich aus
politischer und wirtschaftlicher
Instabilität
solche extremen Ansichten wie die der
auskeeper sind hier keine Rand
Erscheinung im Gegenteil sogar viele der
republikanischen Kandidatinnen und
Kandidaten haben bei diesen Wahlen
solche Töne angeschlagen allen voran
Kerry Lake die ehemalige
Fernsehmoderatorin ist leidenschaftliche
trump-anhängerin und fest davon
überzeugt dass ihm vor zwei Jahren die
Wahl gestohlen wurde
[Applaus]
sie wollen dass wir glauben dass beiden
81 Millionen Stimmen bekommen hat
beleidigt nicht unsere Intelligenz
wenn ich Gouverneurin bin werden wir das
Wahlsystem reformieren und wieder faire
und transparente Wahlen einführen
noch ungewiss
Mike Vogel dagegen hat das Rennen für
den Senatssitz in Arizona nicht gewonnen
doch als Verlierer sieht er sich und die
Demokraten nicht
wir nehmen Einfluss auf den Diskurs wir
sind eine Kraft für den Wandel und der
ist noch möglich da bin ich
hoffnungsvoll
Jay und Mike haben es geschafft in Java
Pai County viele Wählerinnen und Wähler
für die Demokraten zu mobilisieren das
gibt ihnen Antrieb und Hoffnung dass
sich die unruhigen Wogen in ihrem Land
wieder glätten
ja und in Herzberg Pennsylvania ist für
uns Johannes Hano Johannes großer Jubel
bei den Demokraten in Pennsylvania sie
konnten den Swing state von den
Republikanern zurückerobern was bedeutet
das für die Partei von Präsident Joe
Weiden
also erstmal bedeutet es ganz klar dass
sich die Demokraten und Präsident beiden
hier die Chance bewahrt haben auch in
Zukunft eine Mehrheit im Senat zu haben
da muss man jetzt noch abwarten wie das
in den letzten drei verbleibenden
Bundesstaaten ist wie die die jetzt da
noch nicht ausgezählt sind endgültig
aber zumindest hat man sich die Chance
bewahrt den Senat weiter im Griff zu
behalten aber das ganze hat noch was
anderes gezeigt dass die Demokraten
nämlich eine Chance haben gegen auch in
so umkämpften Bundesstaaten wie hier in
Pennsylvania gegen den Trump schon
Extremismus wenn man klare Kante setzt
man hat sich hier ganz klar als
Abtreibungsbefürworter positioniert und
als Verteidiger der Demokratie das ist
vor allen Dingen bei Frauen und jungen
Wählern besonders gut angekommen wie
erst der Analysen zeigen und auch im
ganzen Land wo gab es denn sonst noch
Überraschungen bei den Zwischenwahlen
also die größte Überraschung ist
eigentlich das ist nicht zu einer roten
Welle gekommen ist wie die Republikaner
gehofft und auch vermutet hatten
normalerweise ist in diesen Zeiten
diesen Zwischenwahlen wenn es schlecht
um die Wirtschaft steht jetzt aber auch
noch Inflation dazu bekommen die Partei
des Präsidenten sehr im Hintertreffen
meistens gehen so 30 Stimmen verloren 30
Mandate verloren dazu kommt es wohl
nicht und das ist eigentlich die größte
Überraschung hier aber auch hier haben
die Demokraten im ganzen Land gezeigt
dass er mit klarer kannte dem Tram schon
Extremismus was entgegensetzen kann und
das ist die größte Überraschung das ist
viel enger geworden ist als man das
gedacht hat und wie reagieren die
Republikaner bisher auf die Ergebnisse
also was wir so hören im Moment und was
ihr überall diskutiert wird ist dass man
hoch unzufrieden ist mit der Performance
der Trump Kandidaten das sein
extremistische Kandidaten wenn man mit
qualitätskandidaten wie mit mcConnell
der Führer im Senat gesagt hat
angetreten wäre hätte man wahrscheinlich
den Senat gewinnen können und auch sehr
viel mehr Abgeordneten Sitze für den
Kongress da wird sich jetzt eine große
Debatte geben mit um den trumpismus um
die Rolle von Donald Trump in der
Zukunft da wird es sehr viel Streit
geben und da kann man gespannt sein wie
die nächsten Tage und Wochen hier
verlaufen danke Johannes Hano ja und
dann gehen wir von den USA nach Berlin
dort spreche ich jetzt mit dem CDU
aus-experten Norbert Röttgen da ist er
guten Abend guten Abend Frau Pieper ja
der erwartete Erdrutschsieg der
Republikaner ist ausgeblieben wie
bewerten sie das Ergebnis
ja das ist überraschend mit es wurde
damit gerechnet dass es einen klaren
Sieg gibt vor allen Dingen im
Repräsentantenhaus den mag es jetzt
geben wenn überhaupt dann aber knapp um
Senat ist noch offen also dieser Schub
für Trump den er sich erwartet hatte der
ist ausgeblieben aber klar ist die
Republikaner werden wenn sie das
Repräsentanten aus gewinnen natürlich
stärker werden sie haben dann ein ein
eine Kammer für sich erobert knapp das
wird Schwierigkeiten machen das wird
innenpolitisch für Joe Biden ihn etwas
lähmen aber es wird auch außenpolitisch
die Debatte sich verändern wir werden ab
morgen zwei Jahre lang
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf haben und das
wird die die Diskussion auch wieder
innenpolitisch fokussieren und darum
wird auch Trump darum wird auch beiden
für seine Ukraine Politik die ein
Glücksfall für die Europäer ist stärker
unter Druck kommen von den Republikanern
aber auch von der eigenen Partei sie
haben es ja schon angedeutet was ist ihr
Eindruck wohin steuern die USA in den
verbleibenden zwei Joe Biden im Vorfeld
haben sie ja gesagt die Demokratie in
den USA sei in einem prekären Zustand
ja das ist auch so und das kam ja auch
in ihrem Bericht schon zur Sprache
sind eben auf bundesstaatsebene ich weiß
man wissen jetzt nicht wie nicht wie die
Wahlen ausgegangen sind aber viele der
republikanischen Kandidaten waren eben
Kandidaten die der Parteilinie die
inzwischen Trump durchgesetzt hat bei
den Republikanern folgen das Wahlen nur
dann anerkannt werden wenn nicht
Demokraten sondern Republikaner gewählt
werden das wird auf der Bundesstaaten
Ebene entschieden
dieses Wahlsystem und das ist sozusagen
die die programmierte Ansage wenn Joe
beiden etwa wiedergewählt werden sollte
oder ein kann der Kandidat der
Demokraten dass sie das dass sie
entschlossen sind den Sieg sich nicht
widerstehen zu lassen das ist wirklich
die gefährlich das gefährlichste Moment
bei diesen Wahlen im übrigen glaube ich
wird das jetzt einen einen aggressiven
Wahlkampf von der republikanischen Seite
geben auch mit innerparteilichem
Wahlkampf und darum heißt das für uns
deutsch Europäer wir müssen uns darauf
einstellen dass jetzt die Europäer die
europäische sicherheitsmacht die
wichtigste werden müssen bislang sind es
die Amerikaner aber das wird ein Wechsel
des Schwerpunkts der Debatte und der
politischen Orientierung in Amerika
geben was glauben Sie denn wie wird
Donald Trump auf das Ergebnis reagieren
er hatte ja schon im Vorfeld angekündigt
nächste Woche eine Neuigkeit verkünden
zu wollen also er hat angekündigt seine
Kandidatur anzukündigen da kommt der
auch glaube ich nicht mehr runter ich
denke auch dass er nicht runterkommen
möchte denn wenn er jetzt zurück zuckt
dann zeigt er Schwäche er ist geschwächt
weil der Schub ausgeblieben ist es
scheint auch sozusagen das gerade seine
radikalen Kandidaten schlecht
abgeschnitten haben es wird auch in der
in der Partei so kommentiert hat einen
starken innerparteilichen Konkurrenten
run the Säntis den Gouverneur von
Florida der sehr gut wiedergewählt
worden ist also es wird er wird die
Kandidatur ankündigen ich halte ihn nach
wie vor für den stärksten Mann die
kinderrepublikanischen Partei er hat sie
feindlich erobert und darum wird werden
wir diese Kandidatur mit allem was bei
Trump dazugehört sehen man wird schon in
diesen zwei Jahren mehr von dem sehen
was wir in der Vergangenheit von Trump
gesehen haben keine gute Aussicht aber
auch heute war der die Ansage das wird
ein großer Wahl sie werden große
Befürchtung die Amerikaner sind haben
diese Welle nicht ausgelöst das ist
bemerkenswert vielen Dank Norbert
Röttgen
also fassen wir noch mal zusammen die
Demokraten haben wohl die Mehrheit im
Repräsentantenhaus verloren so sieht es
jedenfalls aus im Senat ist der Ausgang
noch unsicher dass die Partei des
regierenden Präsidenten verliert war
schon in der Vergangenheit meistens so
beiden geht zudem als nicht sehr beliebt
und viele Amerikaner Kreiden ihm die
hohe Inflation an was heißt das alles
für die Politik der nächsten Jahre
Claudia Bates mit einer Einschätzung
hier haben sie den Daumen auf dem Geld
der Kongress segnet wichtige Ausgaben ab
ob es um Schuldenpolitik geht um den
Haushalt Ausgaben fürs Klima oder höhere
Steuern mit einer republikanischen
Mehrheit würden die Untersuchungen zum
Sturm aufs Kapitol beendet stattdessen
würde es Lärm geben Spektakel
Untersuchungen gegen beiden auch mit
einem Amtsenthebungsverfahren haben die
Republikaner bereits gedroht und sicher
fällt ihnen auch noch ein auf welcher
Grundlage
die größte Folge für die Welt wird ein
republikanisches Repräsentantenhaus das
im Wege steht wenn es um Hilfe für die
Ukraine geht und um die Durchsetzung von
umweltschutzgesetzen für das Klima und
die Demokratie in der Ukraine wird ein
republikanischer Sieg wohl ein
erheblicher Rückschlag sogar wenn es nur
das Repräsentantenhaus ist denn das ist
alles was Sie brauchen um den
Präsidenten zu blockieren
Thema Ukraine Präsident beiden und
Präsident selenski waren sich einig die
USA unterstützen die Ukraine massiv die
problematisch mit Waffen mit Sanktionen
gegen den Angreifer Russland und dessen
Akteure von den Republikanern gab es
vereinzelt Kritik an den massiven
Ausgaben aber im Prinzip war man auf
einer Seite bis jetzt
unter republikanischer Mehrheit wird
kein Penny mehr in die Ukraine gehen
unser eigenes Land kommt zuerst
je mehr radikale Republikaner im
Kongress sitzen desto schwieriger wird
es für beiden die Mittel für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine zu bekommen
seine Loyalität zu den Partnern in
Europa ist eisern was danach kommt
unklar
ich würde hoffen dass es noch zwei Jahre
lang stabil bleibt ich denke wenn die
Republikaner auch nur eine
Parlamentskammer übernehmen wird es viel
schwieriger für beiden Außenpolitik zu
gestalten wie zuvor aber sein Bekenntnis
zur NATO da ist er enthusiastisch und
auch alle seine Mitarbeiter man darf
annehmen dass das bis zur nächsten
Präsidentschaftswahl erstmal so bleibt
Thema Klima stolz zeigt der Präsident
sich im elektro-jeep setzt schärfere
Abgasnormen durch und bis 2030 soll die
Hälfte aller Neuwagen elektrisch fahren
hunderte Milliarden Dollar für den
Klimaschutz für die Wände hin zu
erneuerbaren Energien es ist die größte
Investition in saubere Energien in der
Geschichte der USA
Klimaneutralität bis 2050 ist das Ziel
wenn Leute Klima sagen denke ich Jobs
unsere Antwort auf den Klimawandel ist
eine Jobmaschine und bietet riesige
wirtschaftliche Chancen
mit den Republikanern aber geht das
nicht so weiter sie Geißeln beiden dafür
dass er raus will aus der Kohle und kein
öffentliches Land mehr frei gibt für
Ölbohrungen sie verlangen dass die USA
völlig energieunabhängig sind
Thema Wirtschaft hohe Lebensmittel und
Benzinpreise treiben das republikanische
narrativ
Inflation und für die machen die
Republikaner Präsident beiden
verantwortlich sie möchten die
Ausgabenpolitik des Präsidenten beenden
und sonst
sie haben nicht wirklich einen Plan sie
haben Präsident beiden angegriffen
obwohl die Arbeitslosigkeit auf 3,7%
gesunken ist unglaublich niedrig dennoch
sagen sie egal die Inflation ist zu hoch
in feuchten
Thema Abtreibung das Oberste Gericht hat
das liberale Abtreibungsrecht gekippt
viele Republikaner möchten Abtreibung
nun sehr weitgehend verbieten gegen ein
solches Gesetz würde Präsident beiden
ein Veto einlegen
hier ist mein Versprechen das erste
Gesetz das ich ins Parlament schicke ist
das Recht auf Abtreibung
das wird wohl nicht durchkommen denn
wenn die Republikaner hier im Kongress
die Mehrheit haben werden Sie vor allem
innenpolitisch die Pläne von Präsident
beiden stoppen so gut es geht
bei mir im Studio ist jetzt die
Historikerin Britta Waldschmidt Nelson
die die Geschichte der USA bestens kennt
schönen guten Abend schönen guten Abend
wie bewerten sie denn die Ergebnisse der
zwischenwahl
naja es ist eindeutig ein Gewinn für die
Republikaner im Repräsentantenhaus das
wurde auch schon gesagt beim Senat weiß
man es noch nicht aber die große rote
Welle das wurde auch schon gesagt das
ausgeblieben und insofern wenn man
berücksichtigt historisch gesehen dass
in den letzten 100 Jahren bis auf drei
Mal die Partei die nicht das Weiße Haus
kontrolliert mindestens 30 Sitze
verloren hat ist es eigentlich ein
Erfolg für die Demokraten und es war
auch ein sehr unerwarteter Erfolg und
darum freuen die sich jetzt im Moment
und bei den Republikanern ist eher eine
gewisse Frustration vorhanden also sie
haben relativ wenig verloren die
Demokraten im Vergleich im historischen
Vergleich was hat denn ihrer Meinung
nach den Ausschlag gegeben dass diese
rote Welle ausgeblieben ist ich denke
das hat im Wesentlichen zwei Gründe zum
einen haben die Republikaner auf zum
Teil aufgrund von Trumps drängen auf
sehr sage ich mal
risikobeladene Kandidaten gesetzt also
sehr
extreme Kandidaten die sehr unerfahren
waren und halt auch Trumps falsche
Behauptungen die Wahl sei gestohlen
Norden bei den letzten Wahlen
unterstützt haben und das hat sich nicht
ausgezahlt zum anderen denke ich aber
auch dass die Republikaner sich zu sehr
darauf verlassen haben dass diese Themen
die sie in den Vordergrund gestellt
haben das heißt die hohe Inflation die
wirtschaftliche Schwäche die Gaspreise
und so weiter dass das das einzig
entscheidende sein würde die haben den
Demokraten immer vorgeworfen dass sie
sich ja nur auf solche abstrakten Dinge
wie irgendwie Recht auf Abtreibungen und
demokratieschutz verlassen würden aber
jetzt hat sich doch gezeigt dass gerade
bei den Frauen unter 40 diese diese
Frage des Rechts auf Abtreibung was er
durch die Jobs decision im Juni
eingeschränkt wurde bzw die Entscheidung
darüber den Einzelstaaten wieder
überlassen wurde dass das sehr viele
demokratische Wähler jetzt doch
mobilisiert hat ist das heute auch in
den Niederlage für Donald Trump
das würde ich schon so sehen ja auch
wenn die Republikaner gewonnen haben
numerisch und sie werden ganz bestimmt
die Kontrolle bei Repräsentantenhaus
bekommen er hat er ja propagiert es wird
eine große rote Welle geben gerade wegen
seiner Kandidaten die er unterstützt hat
Leute eben wie im Moment aus oder eben
Hercule Walker in Georgia und da
zeichnet sich jetzt eher ab dass diese
extremen trampisten und auch election
Dinners wie sie so schön genannt werden
dass die verlieren und deshalb ist das
für ihn persönlich schon als Niederlage
einzuschätzen blicken wir auf Joe Biden
was glauben sie wird er noch durchsetzen
können es ist natürlich immer schwierig
und das trifft fast alle Präsidenten in
der zweiten Hälfte ihrer ersten Amtszeit
dass sie dann mit einer Blockade im also
dieses divided government umgehen müssen
ich denke Joe Biden wird wenn er Gesetze
durchsetzen kann noch darauf angewiesen
sein dann im Senat Unterstützung zu
bekommen und mit einigen moderaten
Republikanern zusammenzuarbeiten da kann
er innenpolitisch vielleicht noch was
bewegen im Rahmen
wirtschaftsstärkung Inflationsbekämpfung
und ähnliches ansonsten vermute ich dass
er sich dann eher wie auch viele seiner
Vorgänger in der gleichen Situation auf
außenpolitisches Engagement verlegen
wird Außenpolitik ist mein Stichwort wir
sprechen gleich noch mal weiter ja
America first war der Slogan von Donald
Trump einige Republikaner sagte Vorfall
der Wahl es gebe keinen Blankoscheck für
die Ukraine wie also positioniert sich
die einstige weltmacht-usa in Zukunft
gespannt blicken die Bündnispartner und
konkurrierende Mächte wie China und
Russland auf den Ausgang wir haben
unsere großponenten um eine Einschätzung
gebeten und beginnen in Moskau
beschwichtigen das scheint Moskau aus
Motto heute in Bezug auf die
Wahlergebnisse zu sein es gäbe keinen
Grund deren Bedeutung für das
russisch-amerikanische Verhältnis über
zu bewerten sagte gremmelsprecher Peskow
in einer ersten Reaktion da konnte man
in den vergangenen Tagen durchaus einen
anderen Eindruck bekommen ausgiebig
berichtet das russische Staatsfernsehen
über den Wahlkampf immer wieder wird die
Hoffnung geäußert ein Wahlsieg der
Republikaner bedeute dass Ende der
militärischen und humanitären Hilfe für
die Ukraine der Kreml Treue Außenpolitik
Experte Dimitri susloff erklärt das so
natürlich sind die Wahlen für Russland
wichtig da wir mit den Vereinigten
Staaten in einen existenziellen Konflikt
involviert worden sind der sogar ein
intensiveren und gefährlicheren
Charakter trägt als der vergangene Kalte
Krieg
hallo die Sprecherin des russischen
Außenministeriums wiederum behauptet für
Moskau sei es egal wer in Washington
regiere
vor dem Hintergrund des harten
russophoben Konsens kann man sich in den
Beziehungen zu Russland nicht auf den
gesunden Menschenverstand der
amerikanischen Elite verlassen
unabhängig ihrer Partei Zugehörigkeit
das ein Putin vertrauter kürzlich zugab
russland habe sich in die US-Wahlen
eingemischt und werde das weiter tun
wird jetzt als Witz abgetan und der
Präsident beschäftigt sich heute
demonstrativ mit anderen Dingen
Krankenhaus Miniatur statt großer
Außenpolitik
in Brüssel gibt es viele die sich
darüber freuen dass der us-fehler Trumps
Machtanspruch ein wenig gestutzt hat
aber sie machen sich Sorgen um
US-Präsident beiden er droht die
Mehrheit im Kongress zu verlieren dann
könnten die Republikaner beides Europa
freundliche Politik blockieren
Bundeskanzler Scholz und Frankreichs
Präsident macron grüßen die Ukraine
Demonstranten auf dem Gipfel in Prag vor
einem Monat bald könnte auf die
EU-Regierungschefs mehr Verantwortung
zukommen denn die USA verlangen mehr
Führung von Europa das heißt vor allem
bei der Unterstützung für die Ukraine
bisher hat der US-Kongress in diesem
Jahr mehr als 60 Milliarden Dollar für
die Unterstützung der Ukraine bewilligt
die Republikaner wollen diese Hilfe
überprüfen die EU ist mit rund 19
Milliarden in diesem Jahr dabei
ohne Amerikas Waffen und finanzielle
Hilfen hätten die Ukrainer wohl nicht
durchgehalten die Republikaner wollen
dass die Europäer mehr zahlen nehmen Sie
beiden die Mehrheit im Kongress ab dann
kann sich Europa nicht mehr nur auf die
Amerikaner verlassen das Gebot der
Stunde lautet transatlantisch bleiben
und zugleich europäischer werden wir
müssen in Europa strategisch souveräner
werden mit Blick auf Sicherheit und
Verteidigung mit Blick auf Energie auch
erwarten viele in Europa dass die USA
noch stärker ihre heimische Industrie
unterstützt und europäische Firmen
dadurch
Wettbewerbsnachteile bekommen dieser
Amerika first Politik könnte ein Problem
werden
es gibt nicht viele Themen bei denen
sich die Wählerinnen und Wähler von
Demokraten und Republikanern einig sind
die Abneigung gegen China ist aber eines
davon offiziell kommentiert China die
Zwischenwahlen nicht doch die
Staatsführung hier in Peking schaut sich
die Ergebnisse genau an denn die
Stimmung könnte noch frostiger werden
bei den Konflikten geht es vor allem um
Handel und Sicherheit
rund um Taiwan lässt Chinas Militär
immer wieder die Muskeln spielen
und Präsident hi fordert seine Armee auf
ihre gesamte Energie auf Krieg und Ziege
zu konzentrieren
US-Präsident beiden hält an den Zöllen
auf chinesische Importe die sein
Vorgänger Trump verhängt hat weitgehend
fest und ließ gerade neue Beschränkungen
für den Export von hochleistungs-chips
nach China verhängen die Zwischenwahlen
selbst sind bei Chinesinnen und Chinesen
rund um die amerikanische Botschaft in
Peking kein großes Thema wer in zwei
Jahren US-Präsident wird allerdings
schon
ich hoffe nicht dass beiden noch mal
Präsident wird seine Politik ist China
gegenüber total unfreundlich Trump der
ist auch nicht verlässlich psychisch
instabil nicht stabil und emotional
Chinesen hoffen dass wir gut miteinander
auskommen dass die Freundschaft zwischen
den Menschen und den Regierungen
weiterwächst auch die Handelsbeziehungen
das kommt allen zugute China befürchtet
dass ich beiden bis zur
Präsidentschaftswahl noch stärker in der
Außenpolitik engagieren könnte mit einem
Schwerpunkt auf der Rivalität zu China
und in Berlin ist mir jetzt Marie
agnesstrack Zimmermann zugeschaltet
Vorsitzende des Verteidigungsausschusses
des Deutschen Bundestags guten Abend
guten Abend ja in Europa fragen sich
jetzt natürlich viele vor allem welche
Folgen hat das Ergebnis für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine durch die
Vereinigten Staaten einige Republikaner
hatten ja gefordert sich doch mehr um
das eigene Land zu kümmern
also grundsätzlich kann man das
natürlich noch nicht sagen aber das
Ergebnis ist schon für uns eine leichte
Erleichterung sage ich jetzt mal nämlich
dahingehend dass die rote Welle wie
Trump sie angekündigt hat eben nicht
über die Vereinigten Staaten gerollt ist
aber Tatsache ist das Ergebnis ist knapp
und insofern ist es natürlich spannend
wie letztendlich ist am Ende ausgeht ja
worauf sollten sich denn Deutschland
ihrer Meinung nach Einstellen bleiben
die USA der verlässliche Bündnispartner
ja ich glaube das schon es ist ja so
dass der Präsident mit Sicherheit nicht
geschwächt eher gestärkt aus dieser Wahl
herausgeht wir wissen ja von anderen
Präsidentschaften das nach zwei Jahren
der ersten mithörenwahl nach der
Präsidentenwahl das Ergebnis oft
schlechter war insofern hat er nicht
groß geworden aber er hat vor allen
Dingen nicht verloren und angesichts der
Prognosen glaube ich ich kann Joe Biden
erleichtert sein die Frage ist natürlich
für uns sie sprachen nicht gerade an auf
die Ukraine wie geht die Unterstützung
weiter ich bin da relativ optimistisch
wenngleich ich annehmen muss dass im
Repräsentantenhaus in Zukunft deutlich
mehr darüber diskutiert wird wie weit
die Hilfe geht aber grundsätzlich glaube
ich schon dass die Hilfe weiter Bestand
hat und so sind auch die
signalauswashington bisher aber
vielleicht muss auch Deutschland noch
mehr Verantwortung übernehmen
das auf alle Fälle also man kann wenn
sie mit amerikanischen Vertreterinnen
Vertretern sprechen sagen sie immer
keine auf dieser Welt auch nicht die
Vereinigten Staaten haben Angst dass
Deutschland zu viel Macht also im
Gegenteil sondern man erwartet seitens
der Amerikaner dass wir auch gerade in
Europa vor unserer Haustür eben große
Präsenz zeigen in Europa Präsenz zeigen
auch den Mut haben zu führen insofern
wird diese Anspruch bleiben der ist
übrigens nicht neu und gerade im Fall
der Ukraine die Amerikaner machen sehr
viel ja wir machen auch viel aber da ist
noch deutlich Luft nach oben und gerade
bei der Frage welche Waffen wir
weiterhin liefern neben humanitäre
nebenwirtschaftlicher Hilfe führen wir
ja die Diskussion und die werden wir
auch weiterführen müssen was erwarten
Sie wie wird das Weitergehen in den
Beziehungen zu Russland und China
ja die Frage wird natürlich sein und der
Kanzler kam ja aus China zurück und die
wirklich gute Nachricht war dass die
Chinesen Wladimir Putin gewarnt haben
auch nur über ein Atomschlag
nachzudenken das war ein wichtiges
Signal dass auch China die ja am langen
Ende diesen Konflikt auch unterstützt
haben Wladimir Putin war ja während der
Spiele während der Olympischen Spiele in
Peking hat sich grünes Licht geben
lassen das aber bei dem Thema Atom eben
auch die Chinesen im wahrsten Sinne die
rote Karte zeigen das ist von großer
großer Bedeutung aber machen wir uns
nichts vor sowohl China als auch
Russland verbindet eins nämlich die
Ablehnung ich gehe so weit zu sagen der
Hass gegen die freie demokratische Welt
und deswegen ist alles was gerade
passiert sehr sehr ernst zu nehmen in
der Ukraine aber auch grundsätzlich was
unser Verhältnis zu China betrifft
vielen Dank für die Einschätzung Frau
streckzimmermann
ich danke Ihnen
das Gespräch haben wir kurz vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet ja Donald Trump
stand zwar nicht auf dem Wahlzettel und
doch war er bei den sogenannten mit
terms quasi omnipräsent mit seinem oft
maßgeblichen Einfluss auf die
Ausrichtung und die Kandidaten der
Republikaner und mit der ständig weiter
verbreiteten Lüge von den gestohlenen
Wahlen 2020 der bisherige Ausgang der
zwischenwahl war sicher nicht ganz im
Sinne Donald Trumps die wichtigsten
Ergebnisse und Ereignisse jetzt
zusammengefasst von Gerd Anhalt
sieht aus wie ein Faxgerät auf einer
haustierbox ist aber der automatische
stimmenauszähler genannt Tabulator und
wenn er mal nicht ordnungsgemäß
tabuliert dann sind umständliche
Erklärungen nötig
wenn was selten vorkommt der Tabulator
den Wahlzettel nicht annimmt dann
schieben sie ihn hier bei Nummer 3 in
die Box
da ist er sicher und wird später unter
Aufsicht von Vertretern beider Parteien
im tabulationszentrum tabuliert denn
wie ein böser Fluch lag der vielfach
erneuerte und doch haltlose Verdacht der
Manipulation über dieser Wahl und ihren
Tabulatoren brachte viele Wähler an den
Abgrund der Zweifel an ihrer Demokratie
und manchmal darüber hinaus
seit Trump mit der Meer von der
gestohlenen Wahl den Lynchmob seiner
Anhänger auf das Parlament hetzte will
die Lüge nicht verstummen im Gegenteil
nicht wenige republikanische Bewerber
verknüpften ihre Kandidatur damit
vorneweg seine glühende Anhängerin
Carrie Lake die Gouverneurin von Arizona
werden will und den Ball sofort
Aufnahmen
komisch dass solche Vorfälle nicht aus
den Liberalen distriken gemeldet wurden
das ist Unfähigkeit
jedenfalls hoffe ich dass es nicht böse
Absicht war
wie auch immer wir werden das in Ordnung
bringen und wenn wir gewinnen dann wird
hier der richtige Geist einkehren
auch der Erfinder der wahllüge meldete
sich zu Wort wie konnte das schon wieder
geschehen trompetete er das lässt sich
das Volk nicht gefallen noch nie stand
ein Ex-Präsident so im Rampenlicht einer
halbzeitwahl noch nie hat einer das
Klima so vergiftet die Kandidaten so
aufgehetzt und die Themen diktiert und
als er gestern mit Gattin in Florida zur
Urne schlenderte der prophezeiten die
Demoskopen noch eine rote Welle einen
Erdrutschsieg der Republikaner aber als
dann die ersten Stimmzettel ausgezählt
waren und die ersten Ergebnisse Vorlagen
da deutete sich schon an dass die Welle
doch eher nur ein gekräusel war
als nach Mitternacht im heiß umkämpften
Pennsylvania der Demokrat fetter Mann
den Jubel seiner Wähler genoss da war
klar dass Rückenwind vom Donald nicht
notwendigerweise zum Sieg führt
Sozialarbeiter Bürgermeister Vize
Gouverneur Sieger trotz Schlaganfalls im
Wahlkampf eine demokratische
Heldengeschichte
[Applaus]
ich bin stolz auf unser Programm dass
wir Frauen das Sagen über ihre Körper
geben
den Mindestlohn anheben
[Applaus]
Gewerkschaften stärken und die
Gesundheitsversorgung als elementares
Menschenrecht sie hat mein Leben
gerettet und jeder von euch sollte so
etwas haben wenn er es braucht
Trumps handverlesener Favorit der außer
einer Karriere als fernsehdoktor keine
politische Leistung vorzuweisen hatte
konnte sich mit dem Anliegen Amerika zu
heilen nicht behaupten
den nächsten Erfolg für die blauen
verbuchte in Michigan die liberale
Gouverneurin Gretchen Widmer Milizen
hatten sie kidnappen wollen ihre Strenge
corona-politik machte sie zur Hassfigur
der rechten und doch bekommt sie ihre
zweite Amtszeit
[Applaus]
unser Streben gilt auch weiterhin dem
Lösen von Problemen und nicht der
Verteufelung unserer Gegner
ihre Gegnerin ebenfalls ein Trump
Geschöpf wollte das Abtreibungsrecht auf
1931 zurücksetzen und Abbruch nicht
einmal bei Vergewaltigung und Inzest
zulassen
die Schlappen seiner Schützlinge
Schienen Trump nicht anzufechten als er
auf seiner Wahlparty auftrat und einen
großartigen Sieg beanspruchte
die Zahlen soweit sie vorliegen sind
beeindruckend und das schon zu diesem
Zeitpunkt
wir haben 330 Kandidaten unterstützt und
davon haben 200 gewonnen sogar aus
scheinbar aussichtslosen Positionen
in Georgia aber wurde Gouverneur Camp
klar wiedergewählt Republikaner zwar
aber einer der Trumps lügen nicht mit
trug und deshalb übel beschimpft wurde
das Rennen um die Senatoren sitze ist
noch nicht entschieden ob Trumps
Günstling ein ehemaliger Footballspieler
mit instabiler Psyche und Gewaltneigung
noch gewinnen kann ist fraglich obwohl
er ähnliche Zuversicht ausstrahlt wie
seinen Mentor
wer jetzt schlafen geht der Wacht Morgen
auf und sieht dass der neue Senator
herrschel Walker heißt
wer im Staate Ohio schlafen ging der
hatte allerdings schon Gewissheit das
Republikaner JD Vans der neue Senator
sein würde aus bildungsfernem Hinterwald
mit Drogensüchtiger Mutter arbeitet er
sich hoch an die Elite-Uni und in die
Politik seine Lebensgeschichte Hill
Billie elegy war ein Bestseller
vermutlich hätte er es auch ohne Trump
geschafft den er früher widerlich fand
und mit Hitler verglich wandlungsfähig
ist er jedenfalls und der wollte der
konnte den Hauch einer Distanzierung
vernehmen
wie auch immer der Präsident sein wird
unsere Aufgabe ist ganz einfach jeden
Tag hart für die Bürger von Ohio zu
arbeiten und zu kämpfen für die Arbeiter
für die Familien die Drogensüchtigen die
alleinerziehenden Mütter die sich um
ihre Kinder kümmern müssen so wie meine
Mama sich um mich gekümmert hat
es war übrigens bei einem Wahlkampf
Auftritt mit JD Vans in Ohio als Donald
Trump aus Begeisterung über sich selbst
diese viel beachtete Ankündigung
entschlüpfte
making ich werde am kommenden Dienstag
den 15 November in Marler Lago eine sehr
große Erklärung abgeben
was viele dahin deuten dass er
tatsächlich noch einmal für das höchste
Amt kandidieren will dem könnte er
entgegenstehen Rande Säntis alter und
neuer Gouverneur im Konfettiregen
Floridas gilt vielen als
aussichtsreicher republikanischer
Bewerber für das Weiße Haus ähnlich
krawallig wie Trump aber mit Hirn so
wird er von manchen charakterisiert auch
er sagt wie Trump gerne den Untergang
Amerikas voraus
unsere Freiheit unser Way of Life waren
gefährdet und schien sich aufzulösen
aber wir in Florida hielten stand
so empfiehlt sich einer der meint auch
das Land führen zu können mit ihm müssen
die Demokraten rechnen und wohl auch
weiterhin mit ihm denn egal was die
Tabulatoren ermitteln Trump wird sehr
wahrscheinlich weiterhin sagen wir haben
gewonnen oder einfach ich habe gewonnen
und wenn nicht war es Betrug
unser Korrespondentin Washington ist
Elmar Thesen was sagen sie sind die
Zwischenwahlen eine Niederlage für
Donald Trump trotz voraussichtlicher
Mehrheit der Republikaner im
Repräsentantenhaus
ja ich glaube das kann man klar so sagen
aber die also die überwältigende
Mehrheit der Kandidaten die sich in
irgendeiner Weise mit Trump verbunden
haben die von ihm unterstützt wurden
haben bei dieser Wahl verloren das wird
natürlich dazu führen dass man innerhalb
der republikanischen Partei nicht nur
analysiert sondern wahrscheinlich
streitet und zwei heftig ob man lieber
nicht auf Trump setzen sollte auch für
die Präsidentschaftswahl in zwei Jahren
weil jeder der das tut damit rechnen
muss dass eben Menschen motiviert sind
sich gegen solche Extremismus zu stellen
das hat ja wohl den Ausschlag auch bei
dieser Wahl gegeben ja transstärkster
Konkurrent für die
Präsidentschaftskandidatur der
Republikaner ist bisher der Gouverneur
von Florida ronde Santis der einen
klaren Sieg erzielt hat wie gefährlich
könnte der Trump werden und wird Trump
trotzdem wie angedeutet nächste Woche
seine Kandidatur erklären
also ich glaube er kann Trump wirklich
sehr gefährlich werden wenn man sich
allein die Zahlen einmal anguckt ronde
Santes hat in jedem Wahlkreis in Florida
mehr Stimmen hereingeholt als Donald
Trump bei der letzten
Präsidentschaftswahl in diesem
Landkreisen gewonnen hat er hat die
Stimmen von Latinos hinter sich in
Florida und es ist ihm gelungen Miami
Date count jeder sein großer Landkreis
rund um Miami für sich zu entscheiden
und das ist vorher auch nur ganz wenigen
bisher gelungen ich glaube er wäre ein
formidabler Gegner für Donald Trump der
hat ja für den 15 also für Dienstag eine
große Neuigkeit angekündigt aber ich
vermute mal dass er jetzt in den
nächsten Tagen durchrechnen muss ob er
wirklich in den Vorwahlen sich gegen
ronde Santes durchsetzen könnte denn das
Signal das von dieser Wahl ausgeht ist
man will zwar die Inhalte für die Trump
steht aber man will nicht unbedingt die
Form und schon gar nicht den Krawall der
Trump hat ja bereits mit unangenehmen
Enthüllungen gegen disantes gedroht wie
ernst sind denn diese Ankündigungen zu
nehmen
also das wissen wir natürlich nicht
genau aber wir können uns vorstellen
dass wenn es irgendwelche Leichen im
Keller ich sag's mal so salopp von ronde
Santes gäbe dann könnte das ein sehr
schmutziger Wahlkampf innerhalb der
republikanischen Partei werden aber wir
wissen ja auch dass Donald Trump wegen
vieler möglicher Straftaten sich vor
Gericht und in mehreren
Ermittlungsverfahren stellen muss also
im Grunde genommen ist die große Frage
ob er mehr gegen ronde Santes hat als
nur solcher Androhungen und ich glaube
ronde Santes ist einer der sich davon
nicht abschrecken lässt und wie sieht
die Zukunft von Joe Biden aus trotzdem
blauen Auge jetzt bei der mitchams ist
ja nicht zu übersehen dass er ziemlich
unbeliebt ist und ohne Mehrheit wird er
auch nicht mehr viel umsetzen können
oder
ja also wir haben bei unseren Reisen
durchs Land natürlich erlebt dass auch
in tiefblauen Distrikten also da wo die
Demokraten wirklich das Sagen haben dass
die Menschen der Meinung sind das geht
nicht mehr mit Joe Biden erst zu alt man
will einen Generationswechsel eine neue
Anfang das wird schwierig für die
Demokratische Partei jemanden zu finden
aber es gehört zur Wahrheit dazu Joe
Biden hat eben ein historisches
zwischenwahlergebnis jetzt eingefahren
egal ob die Mehrheiten wirklich am Ende
wechseln oder nicht hier im war im
Kongress in Washington also es wird auch
nicht einfach ihm klar zu machen dass er
bitte schön nicht wieder antreten soll
in zwei Jahren vielen Dank MRT wissen
ja und bei mir ist jetzt noch mal die
us-historikerin Frau Waldschmidt Nelson
wie glauben Sie bei denen die repulkaner
mit dem Ergebnis der Zwischenwahlen
jetzt umgehen ja ich denke da wird es
verschiedene Reaktionen geben wir hatten
ja vorher in einem Beitrag auch schon
gehört bei den aus Keepers also auf der
bei diesem graswurzelgruppen die sehr
radikal sind die wird jetzt sicherlich
die Tatsache dass sie vielleicht nicht
beide Häuser übernehmen können in dem
Maße wie sie gehofft haben zu noch mehr
Aggressionen führen ja da will man
mobilisieren da wird man Wahlergebnisse
anzweifeln aber es zeichnet sich meines
Erachtens doch schon jetzt in der Party
leadership also in der oberen Ebene wo
die Entscheidung gemacht haben eher ab
das jetzt gemäßigtere Stimmen laut
werden und dass man tatsächlich überlegt
wie auch im Beitrag gerade schon gesagt
wurde dass die Kandidaten die so
auftreten wie Donald Trump also so
rechtsextremen und also Wahlergebnisse
offen angreifen und auch offen sagen
dass sie Wahlergebnisse nicht
akzeptieren zum Beispiel die nicht zu
ihren Gunsten ausgehen dass man davon
abrücken wird auch wenn wir Herr Thesen
gerade schon sagte die Inhalte
wahrscheinlich die gleichen bleiben
werden im Vorfeld hieß es ja immer bei
den Zwischenwahlen steht auch die
Demokratie in den USA auf den Spielen
welchen Zustand sehen Sie jetzt die
Demokratie in den USA nach der mit terms
also es ist jetzt nicht bestimmt also
bestimmte ich jetzt auf einmal alles gut
aber mir hat diese Wahl so wie sie
bisher verlaufen ist ein bisschen
Hoffnung gegeben zum einen weil das
Ergebnis halt doch etwas weggegangen ist
von der Polarisierung die man vermutet
hat und zum anderen weil die
Wahlbeteiligung ja exzeptionell hoch war
also ich glaube es ist eine der höchsten
Wahlbeteiligung
elections über 50 Prozent und das
bedeutet ja dass die Leute den Glauben
an die Demokratie eben an die Ausübung
ihres Wahlrechts noch nicht aufgegeben
haben und das alleine finde ich schon
ein sehr ermutigendes Zeichen bei allen
anderen vorbehalten die man noch haben
muss ja immer gesagt Donald Trump und
Joe beiden stand nicht auf dem
Wahlzettel ab wer glauben sie wird denn
2024 nach diesem Ergebnis bei den
präsidentschafts antreten ja ich bin
davon überzeugt dass Donald Trump
antreten wird ob er es dann schaffen
kann sich gegen Runde Santis oder einige
andere republikanische Kandidaten die ja
auch schon geäußert haben eventuell
ihren Hut ins renn werfen zu wollen zum
Beispiel Ted Cruise oder vielleicht auch
Chris Christie das weiß man nicht das
kann man jetzt auch noch schlecht bevor
sagen also Herr
prognostizieren aber was die Demokraten
angeht das ist jetzt wirklich ein
bisschen die Gretchenfrage denn an sich
hat natürlich Joe Biden quasi das
Vorkaufsrecht also wenn er entscheidet
er tritt an dann wird er das tun und
dann wird es auch gar keine primary
geben bei den Demokraten aber es ist
halt so die Umfragen zeigen dass jetzt
trotz seines relativ historisch gesehen
relativ guten Abschneidens bei diesen
Zwischenwahlen also dem Abschneiden
seiner Partei das weniger als 30 Prozent
der Demokraten bei Umfragen sich
geäußert haben dass Sie sich das
wünschen würden die meisten haben doch
tatsächlich Vorbehalte aufgrund seines
hohen Alters er wird jetzt eine dieses
Jahres 80 also er wäre 83 beim
Amtsantritt der zweiten Dekade und dann
müsste man mal gucken viele wünschen
sich vielleicht Pete Budget den den
Transportminister ja der auch jung und
dynamisch ist die Leute mobilisieren
können andere denken vielleicht Amy
globischa die so ein bisschen gemäßigter
ist das wird man dann reden wir dann
später vielen Dank für die Einschätzung
sehr gerne ja das war unser ZDF Spezial
zu den Zwischenwahlen in den USA die
Demokraten haben sich besser geschlagen
als erwartet die angekündigte rote Welle
ist ausgeblieben Donald Trump ist ein
Verlierer dieser Wahl obwohl selbst
nicht angetreten und doch die kommenden
zwei Jahre werden für Joe Biden eine
Herausforderung und die wichtige
Entscheidung im Senat steht ja noch aus
viel zu diskutieren und einzuordnen
später im heute journal mit Marietta
Slomka live aus Washington und dann auch
noch im auslandjournal dann sehen wir
uns wenn Sie wollen wieder hier geht es
weiter mit Aktenzeichen XY ungelöst auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]